c'est avec une force rarement vu au
Canada que la tempête Fiona déferle sur
l'est du pays en Nouvelle-Écosse où elle
a touché terre Fiona a endommagé le
réseau électrique des stations services
des racines et des arbres et endommager
des maisons celle de ce résident de
Sydney la plus grande ville du Cap
Breton a été endommagée
la province a d'ailleurs appelé l'armée
en renfort pour l'aider à faire face à
cette situation
aux Îles de la Madeleine les puissants
vents ont aussi causés de nombreux
dégâts couchés des poteaux électriques
au sol renverser les cabanes et détruit
des maisons j'ai entendu des fenêtres
qui cassent et je me suis rendu un petit
peu plus loin puis le premier chalet qui
était enterré j'ai même vu le frigidaire
à sortir et puis prendre l'eau
120 140 km/h vu des photos de toiture
levées complètement pas juste les
bardeaux d'asphalte vraiment la maison
complète situation similaire au
Nouveau-Brunswick des routes inondées
des terrains de camping aussi des
maisons et des résidents prêt à évacuer
c'est la première fois que que je vois
ça comme ça on est la seule je pense la
seule maison dans le quartier qui qui
est sous l'eau le reste des maisons
c'est pas mal plus élevé
malchanceux de ce côté-là mais on va
avec l'assurance va couvrir devant ce
qui est considéré comme une tempête
historique et un événement
météorologique sans précédent des
organismes d'aide mobilisent du
personnel formé pour nourrir hydrater et
abriter et soutenir les premiers
intervenants et les personnes touchées
par la tempête Fiona ici Daniel Kadjo
Radio-Canada Montréal